this is why I think the play is to get
this is why I think the primary is the
general Nikki Haley is the Democrat
she's running in the primary to beat
Trump and she's going to try and beat
him in in major Urban uh uh
strongholds the play here is well it's
basically that they are going to try to
convince Trump reporters that the GOP
Primary it's done deal done deal Trump
can't lose don't even bother coming out
and that might work see cuz everybody's
saying come November everyone must vote
bring your F friends don't assume Trump
will win because that's how they trick
you but in the primary everyone I got
Trump won already and RF RFK gave up on
the primary right he said this is you
know rig rig but at first he was a
Democrat he said this is too rigged I
can't run in there there's another
Congressman believe his name is Dean
Phillips ran he's getting no attention
so well Philip Phillips is doing I think
he's doing okay in New Hampshire right
now so the play is probably let's get as
many Democrats as we can in New
Hampshire and vote for Nikki Hy